so you're about to take a tour of the
nds manufacturing facility that process
begins with the issuance of a work order
at which time the people in the material
area we'll pull what's called a a kit
once that kid is pulled it will be
loaded on to the theatres and the carts
which are then inserted in the pick and
place systems that you're seeing as you
walk through our line
the next process is it goes through a
oven which sauders the parts onto the
board at each point in that step those
boards are being inspected primarily
with machines but also visually at the
end of the surface mount mine and
assemble board then goes through a
couple different inspection processes
one called automated optical inspection
which basically takes a picture of the
board to make sure all the parts are
there and they're all geometrically
aligned and then the second piece as it
goes through an x-ray machine called 5dx
which basically then does a
three-dimensional x-ray on the board to
make sure that all the solder is applied
appropriately at that point there's
final inspection and any secondary
operations that are done manually and
the product if it's just a circuit board
is ready to ship there's another part of
our operation which we call system build
which we do foresee micro and as you can
see the sea micrel product use involves
a number of circuit cards in a large
chassis and at that point there's system
tests that's done and at the conclusion
of a successful test we're ready to
package and ship the product